[Music]
reading this is where we snuff out the
resistance once and for all how do all
the makeup people keep forgetting to put
on his pourable mustache incinerate that
base destroy their transports and
obliterate their fleet well just see
kill everything resistant ship
approaching guns and shields in attack
mode but despite the fact that we're
here to destroy all rebel scum here
today we will talk to the pilot of this
puny ship because it will be an amusing
situation also the first order gets
distracted by this one pilot and decides
not to go ahead and blow away the rebel
base because inside every Empire first
order bad guy is a capacity for love you
gotta take out that last cannon our
bombers are toast
seriously one beam cannon is gonna be
the difference here these guys barely
hit anybody when they have all the
cannons
bb-8 magic quickly devolves into an
electric version of the boy plugging the
wall from that one ancient fable I
forgotten the name of this Marty McFly
maneuver somehow it works
bring the bombs resistance bombers
approaching but why is every member of
this rebel fleet a Poe Dameron ignoring
general Leia's orders this battle sure
does go to ship awfully fast
like so fast they should never even have
attempted it I mean it ultimately ends
with one bomber left to drop bombs they
knew there would be fighters they acted
earlier like Poe taking out the cannons
would make this easy instead it's more
lopsided than Super Bowl 24 this
swarming force of first order pilots
were able to knock out these three
bomber ships without much problem but
now that there's one left they suddenly
get preoccupied with something off
screen that prevents them from ending
this this remote falls completely past
her before she even moves her arm but
because this scene is in slow-mo this
real-life action must also be slow-mo as
she's able to catch it well beyond the
point of no return there's no gravity
and spit hold on I know I've screwed
this up before so let's try this again
there is no force that would cause these
bombs to simply fall straight down onto
the Dreadnought like how gravity works
on earth as we see this once proud
dreadnought explode and cascade of
flames I'm wondering why are all the
other first-order ships useless here
they could fly after the Robo fleet -
right why did they put all their eggs in
the dread basket they can't get away
soup
we have them tied on the end of a string
why wouldn't Snoke know that already
though wait you mean Luke didn't just
stare at Rey and a lightsaber for 25
minutes like he did at the end of the
force awakens she took a tiny step
backwards after handing it to him but it
must have been a fourth step because now
she's a dozen feet away this moment
completely undermines the ending of the
force awakens and does so for a
throwaway joke yes Luke has given up on
the force at this point but you don't
need this gag to sell it he can hand it
back to her solemnly and accomplish the
same thing story wise but you wanted to
subvert audience expectations but
disease that infects this entire film
actually discount Ewoks go away look if
you want Luke to be disillusioned and
turned away from the force fine but Rey
just told him his goddamn sister center
and they need his help he's not I'm
gonna ask about the details just by a
man I have angst over here you think
that I came to the most unfindable place
in the galaxy for no reason at all no
but I do wonder why you left a fool map
to this unfindable place if you didn't
want to be found
[Music]
boobie balls unpasteurized ale a siren
milk but was there any reason he needed
to pull ball to the other side of the
lagoon the bottom pointy end of that
stick is in the same place when he's on
the original cliff as it is after he's
vaulted he just lifts it slightly and
slams it down onto a fish there's no
reason he could have done that at the
start and skip the Jedi Decathlon they
sent me here with hope but not Empire
Jedi geez just imagine going on a trip
with only a new hope and mr. Magorium's
wonder Emporium they were heroes on that
mission a slap I suppose a demotion and
a couple verbal burns
I honestly think Leia is being way too
easy on Poe here he literally caused the
death of like half the fleet they found
us this comes seconds after Leia showed
off her fancy homing beacon Apple watch
seconds also this should be the biggest
duh moment for Poe here right they are
obviously tracking you even if the
tracking through Lightspeed thing is
supposed to be impossible can we jump to
Lightspeed fuel is this the first
mention of the concept of fuel and star
wars I sure don't remember Han in the
original trilogy ever having to worry
about fuel
certainly not for jumps to Lightspeed
and Ray just took the Falcon supposedly
halfway around the universe looking for
Luke but this ship only has enough fuel
for one more jump Jesus because Snoke
ship and evil fleet all come out of
hyperspace here instead of over there
this entire movie is allowed to take
place
ships in this universe only have two
speeds faster than light and impulse
power
unnecessary spinning yes only Poe and
bb-8 survived that hangar explosion what
a lucky narrative break this explosion
doesn't kill Leia
nor does getting sucked out into space
what is the point of all this if we
can't blow up three tiny cruisers Hux
would be excellent at cinemasins
they're faster and lighter sir they
can't losses but they can keep it
arranged where our cannons are
ineffective against their shields
infuriating writing right here suddenly
and for the first time in all Star Wars
ships struggle to catch up to other
ships depend on fuel have limited jumps
to Lightspeed have impulse speed based
in part on their weight also we can have
some kind of near but far ballet of
characters they won't last long banning
fuel like this god damn it I pinpoint at
the moment I gave up on modern Star Wars
movies and it was the fuel it was the
fuel it takes into the last Jedi for
these movies to actually show Leia doing
something with the force other than
telepathic communication also I truly
don't care if you want to introduce new
force powers but a little explanation
goes a long way especially when said new
power is literal space resurrection
isn't she unkillable now where's that
danger or does she only have enough fuel
for one space resurrection it's cute
when the Borges give Chewie grief as
he's about to eat their friend but where
were these assholes back when Judy was
killing their friend or plucking their
friend that's Admiral hold on
battle of Chiron Belt Admiral hold on
dude how do you not know what such a
famous person looks like Star Wars is
weird it's like a long time ago in a
galaxy far away but they have super
advanced space travel and weapons
technology yet no one's invented to
photograph Captain Commander you can
call me whatever you like I just want to
know what's going on of course you do so
begins the completely unnecessary and
runtime bloating let's not tell Poe
what's going on so in Andros we can go
on a side quest that adds an extra
thirty minutes to this movie plot point
what are you doing here hello everyone
meet rose Rose is an escape pod guard
it's as if you can't just lock up the
escape pod Bay and require high-level
access key cards to get in also she's
the last line of defense here she's
lucky a whole bunch of deserters don't
come down here overpower her and just
launch multiple escape pods off the ship
holy she stunned him without even giving
him one second to explain after just
fangirling over him she has no chill we
destroy her and disable the tracker
without them realizing hey won't you
realize it's off for one system cycle
about six minutes what what's a system
cycle - you can turn off a main bridge
class a system but no one notices until
the computer does what sweep of the ship
for any changes to processes and the
ship is so he
to take six minutes hell this movie
knows where it wants all its characters
to be at certain times but gives zero
it's about how and why they get their
hey they're having the secret against
orders mission debrief in general Leia's
hospital room the hey I know a spot
where no one will pay us any mind follow
me I never I hate you
could I do it of course I could do it
but I can't do it yeah sure I make this
easy right real life doesn't have easy
answers but a nice simple plan using
Mads is exactly what this movie needed
and instead the plot will divert to a
whole other planet and make this movie
just as long as transformers the last
night lady neither you nor they have the
time for this kind of Flowery adjective
filled exposition you will find him
ruling at a high-stakes table fight he
plays there 24 hours a day they let him
bang chicks and sleep right there
believe me there is never a time that
that guy isn't at that table also what's
his game can you at least tell them what
game he likes to play at this
high-stakes table I'm not doing this
yeah four would kill him foreshadowing
sorry that pun was pretty forced oh I
can't even force myself to stop holy did
we just stumble into the Dark Crystal
I was cleaning my blaster it went off
this is exactly the excuse I would tell
my ex-girlfriend whenever she caught me
masturbating
oh those things caretakers island
natives they've kept up the Jedi
structure since they were built do they
live forever are their male caretakers
here do they reproduce with spores also
this kind of sounds like slavery like a
powerful dude getting his inherited
cleaned and fixed by the ragged clothes
natives of whatever place his ancestor
decided to build their religious temple
no one will be seated during the climb
up Kung Fu Panda Mountain staircase
yeah but you made your exile camp on top
of a jedi temple that was built on top
of the dark so fleet only got 18 hours
of fuel left
you got a hurry how is there even enough
fuel for your little hyperspace journey
to space Vegas
he went from not eating these things to
allowing them to tear up the bridge of
the Falcon in about an hour you called
me a monster you are a monster seriously
the most compelling this movie gets is
these strange force time calls between
Rey and Kaila but instead of exploring
that further it's just being used as a
reason to let them fight together for
one scene later and then be enemies
again
what you're telling me that the force
can teleport matter now public beach
can't park that shuttle here these
mother Chris honestly couldn't find one
place to park their shuttle that
wouldn't cause trouble for them later
also keep in mind that right after they
parked way down here on this Beach they
had to run to this casino which is miles
away
I understand these rich dicks wouldn't
allow them to park it right there at the
casino but there had to be a better plan
than this Ma said this master code
breaker would have a red plum bloom on
his lapel because she knew he would
never change his jacket or shirt gotta
tell ya these discount horse things just
took me right out of the movie right out
of the universe of Star Wars they are so
out of place here I'm expecting to see
the USS Enterprise also they're trying
to find this master code breaker a guy
had a need to find fast and wrist
parking their ship on a public beach -
fine but sure we have time for a lesson
about how terrible this town is I wish I
could put my fist through this whole
lousy beautiful town and film it and
upload it to pornhub BB hey did you guys
not shoot any coverage why did you just
give me that close-up of her staff mere
centimeters from the rock only to cut
straight to a wide shot of her and her
staff several feet away from the rock
movie continues to go out of its way to
make these caretakers lives miserable
then medical frigate is out of fuel and
it shields it down gotta ask since we
just saw Finn and Rose flying through
hyperspace a minute ago in this Cruiser
can the rebels not take fuel from all
the smaller ships and hook up the
medical frigate with it or is this some
Star Wars thing that only Star Wars
people know where everything uses
different kinds of fuel unless you got a
defeater pocket our plan is shot Finn
and Rose just happened to get thrown
into the cell where the collector is and
yeah he knows how to do this they need
done why not I mean after all man has
told us only one person in the universe
could do it so stumbling on another
person shouldn't be too hard it's
amazing how far this movie went to make
a throwaway joke this guy with this
talent has just been sitting here biding
his time until the right rescuer came
along there's a fucking sewer grate in
the middle of the prison walkway that's
right folks not a jail set up with
regular plumbing or anything but an
actual goddamn escaped sewer also could
these assholes not be bothered to
replace the grate on either side of
their escape route maybe make it
somewhat hard to find out where you went
stop enjoying this opera join the stofan
I am decidedly not enjoying this
so these giant horse goat things just
run headfirst through walls I guess they
know they'll be able to bust through and
won't slam at a steel or concrete good
on the beach does he think she's
controlling the scooping wait is the
movie saying she is controlling it
Hiro's nearly fall off a cliff and slide
right to the edge of their deaths cliche
how the fuck did DJ get a ship and find
them this motherfucker is a luck dragon
tell Falco I said hello left
I guess Disney is on a quest to cast
Benicio del Toro and as many of their
franchises as possible animals that seem
more important at first than they really
are
but the pastime kill it if you have to I
see only way to become what you were
meant to be and that my friends was the
mantra recited during the writing of the
script and direct relation to the Star
Wars franchise you gotta admire the
balls on this movie I almost want to
remove sins for it being so ballsy but
you know how we do Brian Johnson and
Star Wars troll you can now roll the
footage from a few good men here you
can't handle the truth
so did I but hey at least you found some
mirrors if I go to him Ben solo will
talk she seems super sure about this
after spending basically the entire
movie whining about how she doesn't know
anything about the force and what's
going on inside Yoda and Ghost Yoda
waited a long time to make another
appearance also Yoda looks like an actor
who actually died in real life and then
they found archived footage to put him
into this movie if ghosts Jedi can do
this then they should have been a lot
more helpful in the last two trilogies
but that library contains nothing that
the girl Rey just not already
grammatically this is a clever way of
disguising whether or not the library
itself and the text they're in wherever
actually important for par sets to go
this thing really clicks I guess aren't
you going at Lightspeed isn't that the
same for all ships
it's just that main Cruiser now and that
fuel reserve our experts say it's at
maximum storytelling level sir tell us
that we have a plan that there's hope I
swear too fuzzy Zeus on a cracker if one
more person says hope I'm going to lose
my Star Wars movies are hereby forbidden
from ever again using the word hope if
you prefer to cast soccer player Hope
Solo in a movie you better change her
name in the credits I'm serious polar on
our way back to the fleet how the hell
are they having this radio conversation
Wow in Lightspeed
so far huh that's weird
that one shield just flipped I guess
there's no reason to radio down and have
somebody check that out a stormtrooper
are doing what you mean to tell me that
Poe who proudly gave Finn his name still
refers to him as a stormtrooper and
doesn't she know who the Finn is you
have bet the survival of the resistance
on bad odds and put us all at risk
considering this is her response to
finding out about Finn and Rosa's side
mission um no he didn't he created an
entirely detached mission for a couple
folks that might ultimately aid the
resistances fight while not detracting
them from their current battle even one
bit
mutiny full-blown mutiny all because
hole dough didn't share her plan and Poe
thinks he's resistant to Jesus and
they're all wrong
clear the bridge escort the officers
down to the hangar this movie totally
rips off Crimson Tide here in the middle
of a third act and I'm pretty sure it's
just to stretch the runtime of an
already bloated movie how is the
troublemaker
I like him hate you oh you do not this
guy has insulted you called you a
traitor disobeyed orders started a
mutiny and other than looking like Oscar
Isaac oh hold on ooh the first order was
she tracking our big ship they're gonna
water track for the transports we could
slip down to the surface
unnoticed and high until the first order
passes yep and why couldn't hold Oh tell
him that again if there was fear of a
mole being on the ship that would have
made this whole surprise make sense
instead hold on made a known
troublemaker panic about the situation
and forced his hand to try something
else that might have messed up her plan
also all those plan relies on the first
order not tracking their transports fine
but this also suggests that they would
never suspect the rebels to board escape
pods once they got within firing range
that they just sit there during an
attack and die peacefully the first
order doesn't know about escape pods
right it was a big plot point a new home
I didn't destroy the Empire also also
couldn't they also see you with their
eyeballs
you're not cloaked you're a couple
doesn't escape capsules leaving a main
shit they can see you right why are they
marching prisoners to the main launching
bed I see him turning the lightsaber to
strike true
while this turns into one of the movies
signature scenes I've got to wonder
about the nature of this action Snoke
can obviously sense kylos intentions so
how is he able to tell Snoke he intends
to kill ray while making a deliberate
action to kill him at the same time
without being found out awesome even
remove a sim worthy but the snow we
built this guy up throughout the first
movie and now we're killing him near the
end of the second one without an ounce
of explanation as to where he came from
by the way whatever happened to the
Knights of Ren didn't they exist
weren't they a thing in the force
awakens rather could they go this is the
way action should basically work minimal
cutting and a well choreographed fight
with no shaky cam or extreme close-ups
of random things hope other directors
are watching this it only took us nine
minutes a movie time to figure that out
so why not drag out their deaths even
longer so that something might save them
also for fuck's sake can the movie make
one logical decision these two are not
major resistance figures phasma hates
him because of personal reasons but
these are not the kind of resistance
heroes you'd say this about holy oh what
a shocker
Finn and Rose and all the people
important for the story are still alive
after Holden's Lightspeed badassery
captain phasma and this cadre of
stormtroopers still care about killing
Finn and Rose after all that and by the
way wasn't fast enough giving the order
to kill them just before the whole duel
maneuver are you telling me that after
that she brushed herself off went to
another part of the ship rounded up some
stormtroopers then came back to kill
them Finn has been wasted this whole
movie so let's have him square off at
the end against phasma who has also been
wasted this whole movie brilliant
someone needs to get snoke's legs an
agent because they have amazing dramatic
timing how long are these Thai fighters
been shooting at Snoke ship currently
being flown by Finn and ROS and can't
hit it until the last minute the first
order true to form LANs binocular
distance away from the rebel base rather
than simply landing right next to the
giant metal wall that they are going to
spend the next 15 minutes slowly
approaching oh I guess the rebels didn't
care much about fire codes when it came
to building this base it's a hefty fine
no wonder they didn't last long here I
can't send this enough how far away
these assholes landed from the base the
rebels have flown for quite some time at
this point and those first order dicks
are still ants on the horizon
oh yeah there's also a bunch of ice
wolves on this planet it's like the
brainstorming session where no
suggestion is mocked somehow became the
actual writers room King Rose why the
fuck did she do this he
about to sacrifice himself to save
hundreds of people and she does this she
was gonna do something that was gonna
potentially end her own life why didn't
she just crash headfirst into the cannon
instead of preventing thing from doing
it now yeah everybody rose I hope you're
happy that's how we're gonna win not
fighting what we hate season what we
love also letting someone smash into a
cannon that would have saved hundreds of
lives would have worked ooh
but sure what an empowering message of
stupidity King Michael babe he's
stalling so we can escape but she would
have been nice for Luke to tell them
that before he went out to confront Kyla
maybe even tell them where some exits
are hell maybe even help create an exit
since a fairly Jedi are like God now but
I guess having PO figure it out for
himself and figuring ray would come to
save the day was good enough when I kill
you I will have killed the last shut up
roll credits surprisingly close to the
credits though well I guess we need to
read the big book of Jedi tricks that
have never been in one movie up until
now seventh edition to understand how
Luke is projecting himself light-years
away from this spot so the bracelet or
necklace or whatever that Luke gave Leia
was also a hologram even though it looks
and acts like a physical thing and I
have a number of questions about it but
Luke died like three minutes ago but I
guess this explains why we lose 21
Holograms when we die Master how the
fuck did they hear this story already
casual Jedi
[Music]
so you'll want to be a cinephile you
want to deepen your lava film while
expanding your horizons into new styles
genres influencers aisle towards want to
feel like you're in on a cool secret get
out of the five dollar bin at the
superstore and get your ass to movie
comm slash cinemasins movie is a movie
streaming service with one goal
introduce you to great cinema they offer
a hand-picked selection of the best
films from all over the world indie
films foreign films classics you've
never heard of experimental films
lesser-known movies from iconic
directors movies experts introduce a new
film that they love every single day and
every movie stays on the platform for a
full month and movie works great on your
PC tablet mobile device and even your
Smart TV so no matter where you are you
always have access to 30 great hidden
cinematic gems they have the internet on
computers No and right now cinema since
fans can get a full month of movie for
free do you know how many movies you can
see in that 30 days no Amelie like way
more than that like 60 and 3/4 a hole
that's $0 and a complete and total lack
of sets but plenty of sense because free
always makes sense
you see everything don't you I do just
head to movie comm slash cinemasins to
sign up and start exploring the
handcrafted selection of some of the
best films ever made we love it and we
think you will do ever since cinemasins
began the most requested thing has been
TV since and now it's a reality click
the link in the description below to
check it out
and now the audio outtakes takes at
ridiculous
there is unconscious but recovering just
like Gerald Ford that spark this
resistance must survive we're going to
live on
we're going to survive today we
celebrate our Independence Day
[Music]
[Applause]
so stupid why'd you do that the sauced
open rose I wanted to do that lie past a
child in a mosque you're an errand boy
sent by closely
[Music]